in the wake of Fredo Cuomo's meltdown
many prominent conservatives or taking
CNN's side and President Trump is
furious we will explain two
diametrically opposed approaches to
grace and politics and then actually
another scandal involving another CNN
host coincidentally that took place at
one of my favorite bars in New York
we'll get into that then President Trump
signals an eagerness to pass new gun
control laws a prominent evangelical
musician loses his faith and more lurid
details emerge in the neverending
Jeffrey Epstein saga
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
so Fredo goes unhinged Chris Cuomo of
CNN Fame and Cuomo family democratic
politics Fame all of the Conservatives
make fun of them you know I made fun of
him I'm still making fun of him I spent
basically 10 hours on Twitter just
making fun of him a lot of conservatives
were going after Chris Cuomo I did point
out I said I don't want public figures
to be accosted just for expressing their
viewpoint that's not a good precedent
but nevertheless this was a hilarious
interaction on the right one of the
biggest Trump defenders on the right
Sean Hannity went on his Fox show and
gave not just a kind of both sides yeah
it's hilarious but you know look we
maybe we shouldn't encourage this he
gave a full-throated defense of CNN's
Chris Cuomo here's Sean Hannity this
video surfaced showing a pretty tense
altercation between Chris Cuomo CNN and
another man who was lobbing insults he
started it gotten Cuomo's face and by
the way his 9 year old daughter and wife
were there that's not on Twitter I
defended Cuomo he did not start this
because I don't support harassment of
any public figure especially in front of
their children and their family and
their wife the person in this country
should be taunted because of their
political beliefs or opinions and with
that said Fredo is designed to be an
insult meaning in other words Fredo the
Corleone family I wanted this for
Michael I never wanted this more for
anybody else okay it was an insult he
was like the dumb brother in the show so
he's insulting Chris Cuomo and Chris has
a right to defend himself and let's not
be phony here everybody
we've all heard those words before we've
watched YouTube and anyone fading out
rates like oh your precious ears never
heard these words before frankly you're
probably full of it or if you act
offended you're just acting like a
liberal that are offended by everything
all right so that's this full throated
of Defense's against when he was on
Twitter Sean Hannity said quote good for
Cuomo good for Chris Cuomo for fighting
back President Trump didn't like that
very much
and we know that President Trump and
Sean Hannity have a relationship and
he's brought Hannity onstage to stump
for him and he watches Hannity's show he
didn't like that very much here's what
President Trump tweeted
he said quote it always happens when a
conservative does even a fraction of
what Chris Cuomo did with his lunatic
ranting raving and cursing they get
destroyed by the fake news but when a
liberal Democrat like Chris Cuomo does
it Republicans immediately come to his
defense we never learn now he might have
been pointing at other conservative
figures but I think President Trump was
aiming this almost squarely at Sean
Hannity so what do we make of this who
wins here who's correct the Hannity
approach defend Chris Cuomo completely
no mocking Chris Cuomo no just total
defense of him or this Trump approach of
go for the jugular because what
President drunk did as a result of this
Aquila video he didn't say look Cuomo
he's an okay guy hey we shouldn't do
this no instead he started selling
t-shirts on his campaign website is a
Fredo unhinged and it's these black and
white zuman's on Chris Cuomo face from
the video and it says text Fredo two
eight eight zero two two
I assume this is a way to to sign up for
the Trump campaign he's selling it for
thirty four bucks by the way if you're
ever curious what I want for Christmas
for my birthday
that is the t-shirt so he establishes
the principle and Trump is completely
right about this this general rule in
politics the left goes for the jugular
and we play by the Marquess of
Queensbury rules the left is engaged in
a dirty rotten street fight where there
are no rules and we're engaged in a very
sophisticated boxing match and and Trump
says enough of this we shouldn't do that
and he sells this t-shirt I think Trump
gets this basically right to a point I
don't care that Chris Cuomo yelled at
that guy I want to live in a society
that is defined by grace where we don't
just go out and harass every public
figure we're a public figure can go out
with his family and have a couple drinks
and maybe loses temper a little bit and
have it not be the end of the world
i won
to live in that society that's the human
and better society but the left won't
operate in that society we would do it
the right always wants to do what we've
been doing it in even in this Chris
Cuomo scandal even all the way up to
Sean Hannity who is one of the biggest
programs on cable but the left doesn't
do it there are whole organizations on
the left that exist to get right-wing
media personalities fired whole
organizations that exist to get Hannity
and Tucker and Laura Ingraham and Ben
and Drew and me fired just last week
Media Matters took a shot at all of us
here at the Daily wire they called us a
cesspool of bigotry and hatred and they
tried to get us all to lose our jobs and
they did it by trying to organize
advertiser boycotts to to kick us out of
our jobs the right doesn't even have
those organizations but the left hates
us so much that they won't even not
forget the politicians they won't even
let the commentators speak they so have
no arguments to respond to us they have
so little to say they're so afraid of
what we're gonna say that they go after
us the commentators just last week the
New York Times the grey lady blamed us
for mass shootings the New York Times
here's the headline quote how the El
Paso killer echoed the incendiary words
of conservative media stars the
alternate headline how the El Paso
gunman echoed the words of right-wing
pundits so how are we supposed to
respond what are we supposed to do what
does this mean for another big scandal
coming out of CNN the coincidentally
took place at one of my favorite bars in
New York we'll get to that in a second
but first if you want to give a truly
meaningful gift you have got to try
paint your life dot-com I've told you
about paint your life I gave this to my
step-brother for his wedding when I
first heard about paint your life it's
this amazing product so you can have an
original painting of yourself or your
children or your family or your little
dog Fido or a beautiful place that you
love you can just take you take a
photograph you upload it they hire an
actual painter like a fine artist who
paints and oil and or however else you
want to paint it they will make you an
original piece of art that you will
work with them the whole time you'll be
getting proofs at a price you can afford
and that's the key because if you want
to commission artwork that can cost
thousands and thousands of dollars but
you can get an incredible product I
don't understand how they can charge
this price at paint your life calm it's
a true painting done by hand there's no
tricks no smoke and mirrors it's done by
a world-class artist created from a
favorite photo you choose the artist
whose work you admire the one that they
did of my step-brother is absolutely
gorgeous it's in Grand Central Station
it's just incredible I am commissioning
more work from that artist it's so great
right now as a limited time offer you
get 30% off your painting do not miss
out on this guy's this is the coolest
gift the minute I saw it I immediately
decided I was going to order some more
30% off and free shipping get this offer
text Knowles kano wles 248 48 48 do it
right now Canha wles 2 for 8 for 8 for 8
text KO wles 2 48 48 48 message and data
rates may apply so you've got the New
York Times even blaming not the
politicians but conservative
commentators for mass shootings that
were perpetrated by the way one by an
eco fascist and another by an avowed
leftist who supports Elizabeth Warren I
mean that's the lengths they're willing
to go to and yet we're really nice to
Chris Cuomo we're really nice to the
left wing commentators they can't answer
our arguments they're afraid of what
we're gonna say they try to get us fired
and then we point out that we actually
don't care if Chris Cuomo loses his
temper after a couple coca-cola's
without with his family at a beer garden
president Crump completely has a point
on this now I disagree in so much as I
think the way we should handle this is
we should still state the principle we
should go out there and say look I don't
care I don't care if Chris Cuomo goes
out and wants to have a couple drinks
but we live in this graceless society
and you're gonna get one of ours and
we're gonna get one of yours and then I
then we should organize advertiser
boycotts and get Chris Cuomo fired not
because I want to not because what Chris
Cuomo did merits him getting fired but
because they do it to us and we cannot
unilaterally disarm there's nothing good
or moral or
Jewess about unilaterally disarming and
letting the left destroy our entire
culture and our politics there's nothing
good about that there's nothing moral
about that we should go out there we
should wear our Fredo unhinged t-shirts
we should make it so miserable for CNN
that maybe maybe just maybe they'd
reconsider their actions and that's that
spirit we should turn to another scandal
also involving CNN involving another CNN
host Don Lemon this one has a really
personal resonance to me because it took
place at one of my favorite bars in New
York
Murph's backstreet Tavern in Sag Harbor
New York so there this is being reported
that there was an incident at a bar
involving Don Lemon at a New York Bar
it's not really a New York Bar like the
city it's actually like three hours
outside the city it's out in the
Hamptons which is this ritzy part of
town ritzy part of Long Island where the
the beautiful people all go out you know
like the Kardashians are in Southampton
that kind of thing it's a ritzy place
that New Yorkers go for the summer even
though the beaches aren't actually that
nice it's close enough and people take
the train out or the jitney and they
they go out there so all the bars are
way overpriced and they're not very fun
and they're there just aren't a lot of
great spots out there except for Murph's
Murph's is this great dive bar in Sag
Harbor which is the best town in the
entire Hamptons it's the last like truly
patriotic old whaling town it's
mentioned in Moby Dick it's just a great
spot great bar but I mentioned that it's
like a true dive bar because people get
real drunk at Murph's I've spent a
number of nights at Merv's and it's like
a real it's not one of these fancy
frou-frou like you're gonna order a sex
on the beach or you know I don't know a
Cosmo or something it's like a place
where you drink beer and you know you'll
have a couple shots or something and so
anyway this is what happens there's a
guy suing Don Lemon for emotional pain
and suffering and why is that and also
for for damages he says he can barely
work anymore what happened was there at
Murph's one night and this guy Dustin
hice is a bartender at a different bar
in the Hamptons and he sees Donlan
Merv's Smurfs is a really tiny bar I
mean it's like the size of my studio or
smaller and you know that I broadcast
from a broom closet
so it's this tiny bar and he sees Don
Lemon across the way and he he tries to
get Don lemons attention and Don Lemon
doesn't pay him any attention and then
he tries to buy Don Lemon a drink and
Don Lemon says oh no thank you I'm just
gonna be over here with my friends fast
forward to the end of the night
everyone's had a couple adult beverages
a few coca-cola's at this point and this
is allegedly what happens lemon quote
put his hand down the front of his own
shorts and vigorously rubbed his
genitalia removed his hand and shoved
his index and middle fingers in the
plaintiffs mustache and under the
plaintiffs nose and asked do you like
and then I'll substitute the words
female genitalia or male genitalia and
then they all sort of laugh and Don
Lemon leaves so as a result of this
alleged incident the guy is demanding
one and a half million dollars from Don
Lemon not to sue said I'm gonna sue if
you don't give me a million and a half
bucks I've been in I mean that's a
pretty bad altercation if it happened I
don't I certainly wouldn't have enjoyed
that but I've been in some bars where
you know bar fights are going on people
are getting kind of nasty with each
other and I've never been in a situation
where I felt I was owed a one and a half
million dollars for something that
happened to me in a bar if someone like
amputated my leg or something maybe I
could sue for a million and a half
dollars but some guy gets ugly with you
I don't know about that so Don Lemon
refuses he said he didn't do anything
wrong now the guy is suing did it happen
I don't know maybe it did Don lemons
kind of a jerk it seems like and people
get extremely drunk at that bar so maybe
on the other hand it also kind of sounds
like the guys extorting Don Lemon we've
heard of plenty of fake sex scandals
over the past ten years especially
involving media figures plenty of
overblown ones plenty of attempts to
extort a wealthy guy so maybe it did
maybe it didn't I don't know but that's
the conservative reaction right my
reaction is the conservative reaction
measured fair you know maybe
happened maybe it didn't I'm gonna
reserve judgment imagine if there were a
lawsuit like this against Fox News
against Bill O'Reilly there was there
was a lawsuit against Bill O'Reilly he
was gone in two seconds gone like that
what imagine if there were a lawsuit
like this that that Sean Hannity or
Tucker Carlson went into a bar in the
Hamptons or wherever and did that to
himself and then took his hand out of
his pants and put it in a woman's face
Imagi cos Don Lemon is gay let's say it
happened to a straight guy Hannity or
Carlson did it and a woman's face could
you omit that not only would they be
immediately kicked off of the air they
would it be there would be criminal
penalties I mean there would be a true
mob outside of their door trying to make
them pay imagine if it were against us
imagine if there were some lawsuit
against us I don't know I go to MuRF
sometimes - maybe some guy got angry at
me and Merv's it would be over there
wouldn't be a question about it the left
would demand our heads they would call
our advertisers every single day and
this is the ugly fact about politics the
left and the right are playing by
completely different rules and president
Trump shows us a little bit how we
should react to that what we should do
moving forward we will examine the only
choice that we have then we'll get to
gun control we'll get to an evangelical
leader losing his faith we will get to a
whole lot more but first we've got to
thank our friends over at ring rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
and they are doing just that they are
protecting millions of people everywhere
safety matters
I know people sometimes don't think
about safety because young people feel
like we were going to live forever and
we don't want to pay for things like you
know I don't know insurance or security
systems or we just don't think I had
that much because nothing could happen
to us I'm on the road a lot I travel a
lot to travel to different colleges and
give speeches around the country the
fact that there is ring makes me feel so
much safer because look sweet little
Elise is a good shot but better safe
than sorry
what ring does is it helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you get an alert
and you are
to see hear and speak to whoever is
there all from your phone so let's say
it's a guy trying to rob your house in
the middle of the night this happened to
my friend a few months ago then you can
see them you can talk to them you chase
them away let's say it's your
mother-in-law comes shows up unannounced
you can see her and then you can zip
your mouth and be very very quiet still
until she just walks away you can do any
of that from anywhere your office the
beach upstairs in your bedroom as a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and
motion-activated floodlight camera the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home it is incredibly inexpensive
it's an unbelievable value and you just
feel like you're in the future I mean
your this is just obviously the way
we're gonna protect ourselves in the
future you can get it today go to ring
comm slash Knolls kenda wles ring.com
slash knowles kayano wles an incredible
product so this is the ugly fact about
our politics is that the left and the
right are playing by two different rules
other than Trump because Trump isn't
really on the right or the left is he I
mean he's been very conservative as
president he's been one of the most
conservative presidents probably in
American history but throughout his
career it's not like he was some rigid
right winger he was donating to Hillary
and Pelosi and playing both sides of the
aisle he said he was a New York
Republican or in New York independent or
he was pro-choice now he's like very
pro-life he's a not a rigidly
ideological guy and I think this has
helped him because he gets down in the
mud he's a New Yorker you know a chris
cuomo on that tape is screaming I'm
gonna throw you down the effing stairs
that is a little bit of a New Yorker
reaction and Trump kind of has that
reaction - so what does Trump do he
doesn't scream at people like a maniac
on a hidden camera
but he'll tweet out unsubstantiated
rumors about his political opponents I
mean he tweeted out the Clinton
body-count the other day and it was
hilarious it was really funny it was one
of the best moments on Twitter during
the 2016 campaign President Trump
actually promoted a rumor that Ted
Cruz's father murdered President Kennedy
I'm not defending that per se I'm just
saying it's a diss
in between how Trump fights and how the
right traditionally fights I wish that
we lived in a gracious society where we
all played by the Marquess of Queensbury
rules but in a world where the left
fights dirty and unfair and cheap and
awful and they get a lot of cultural
victories because of that it is
refreshing that we have a guy who's
willing to get down in the muck with
them especially because we don't want to
I don't want to get down in the muck
like that
so if President Trump is willing to do
it I'm really glad he's the kind of guy
Prince t-shirts that say Fredo unhinged
it's not nice but that is why we elected
him it's why we had to elect him and by
the way if the left doesn't want us to
elect him again then cut it out there's
an easy way for us to not have to have
more Trump's in the future at this point
I'm perfectly willing to give Trump like
a third fourth fifth sixth tenth term in
office he's gonna be 150 years old by
the time he leaves and then I'm gonna
give it to Baron Trump I mean I am
really happy with generally how things
are going in the country if the left
doesn't want us to keep up these tactics
which are the same tactics of the left
and they got to cut it out because we
are not going to unilaterally disarm
that is nonsense
there is nothing virtuous about that
there's nothing moral about that they
need to stop trying to get all our shows
cancelled they need to stop pouncing on
every non traversée they need to do this
three times in a row because I'm not
gonna believe it the first time they let
it go if they did it once that would be
nice three times in a row there needs to
be some kind of non traversée and they
need to be gracious about it and they
need to not try to get our guys thrown
out of office and then do not try to get
our shows cancelled over nothing they
can still fight fair but they need to
stop fighting unfair three times in a
row then we can back off if they extend
us grace three times in a row at the
highest levels I'm not even talking
about the random Twitter accounts just I
want their presidential candidates not
to call half the country white
supremacists three times in a row
I want the New York Times to not blame
me for the mass shooting in El Paso and
Dayton Ohio which was bile is Warren
supporter they do that three times in a
row we're good until then it's game on
what other choice do we have
now speaking of President Trump we're
talking about all the great aspects of
President Trump we need to talk about
some
thing that's not so great that's a
little dangerous that is President Trump
on gun control so president Trump has
signaled after those shootings a couple
weeks ago he shoots signaled that he
wanted certain kinds of gun control he
was very careful about how he was
talking about it but he still signaled
he wanted more gun regulation we've seen
him do this before he passed a gun
regulation after the Las Vegas shooting
which was to ban what's that thing
called the instrument that lets you fire
a bunch of a semi-automatic gun and make
it look as though it's an automatic gun
bump stock bump stock so he banned bump
stocks which was completely pointless
it's not going to save any lives it is a
rounding error it's nothing but it's a
virtue signal forget the fact that the
vast majority people who were killed
with guns in this country are killed by
handguns not by ar-15s not by any other
guns and certainly not by bump stocks he
still banned them I think sort of
pointlessly now the New York Times is
reporting so take it with a grain of
salt the president Trump is considering
more gun control they write quote mr.
Trump on Sunday telephoned Senator Chris
s Murphy a Democrat who has been one of
the leading voices in Congress for gun
control an indication that the president
is interested in pursuing legislation
earlier in the week mr. Murphy had
contacted the White House to indicate
that he was willing to work with mr.
Trump on the issue which prompted the
call the conversation was positive with
mr. Trump indicating that he was serious
about persuading Republicans to act
according to officials familiar with
their discussion bad idea it's just a
bad idea there is no gun control law
that would have prevented the shooting
not the shooting in El Paso not the
shooting in Ohio not the many many many
many more shootings that are not talked
about in the mainstream media not all
the shootings in Chicago not all the
shootings all around the country not the
gang violence not the drug violence not
the suicide which is the most it's the
majority of gun deaths
it won't stop any of them it will just
take away our liberties for no reason
other than to empower the left and to
empower the
which in the long run is the left and
the left is the government in the long
run a very bad idea it's just emotional
I mean the New York Post had that awful
editorial a couple of weeks ago said we
need to ban assault weapons even though
we can't define assault weapons we need
to ban them and not just the cosmetic
features but the different the features
that really differentiate assault
weapons from other rifles even though
there aren't any features that
substantively differentiate assault
weapons quote-unquote from other rifles
nothing was just we need we need to act
now it's this it's this constant push of
emotivism of I don't care about the
facts the facts be damned I need to feel
better about myself this gets you into a
lot of trouble and it not just at the
political level it gets you into trouble
on the culture gets you into trouble on
religion we'll see that with a major
evangelical figure apparently losing his
faith we'll see how it's actually the
same cause it's this emotivism it's this
giving yourself away to emotion I really
hope that President Trump doesn't push
from work gun control there is no
appetite in the country for it over the
long run there is no defense of it
constitutionally or legally from our
political tradition or morally as far as
I can tell and I think it's just him
being suckered in on this emotivism by
Democrats now Trump is not a sucker I
hope he doesn't allow himself to be
played as one and if he does push for
gun control as it appears that he may be
trying to do I hope that Senate and
congressional Republicans stand firm and
do not give an inch on it it's it's
stupid it's a just a terrible idea and I
suspect it's being pushed by forces
around the president that are left-wing
to begin with
stop it get rid of it it won't help you
in 2020 it won't help our liberties in
this country it won't help our
constitutional government it won't help
anybody but the left I want to get to on
this topic of emotivism I want to
discuss how this affects not just
politics but culture and religion we'll
get to that in a second but first we
have got to talk about being prepared in
any emergency and you know I mean this
ties right in especially with some of
the legislation being tossed around you
need to be
prepared things are uneasy in this
country we're not just talking about
economic crises we're not just talking
about political crises talking about
natural disasters I mean I live in
Southern California which means at any
moment god forbid the earth could open
up and I could fall into a pit into the
center of the earth wise company takes
an innovative approach in providing
dependable simple and affordable
freeze-dried food for emergency
preparedness and outdoor use
wise company meals are designed to
protect your family's most valuable
asset yourselves you your family your
wife your kids you you that is your most
valuable asset you protect everything
else you insure your house you insure
your car you insure all of that insure
your family when government resources
are strained it can be days if not weeks
before you can get to fresh food and
water if you're like me you don't you
try not to think about this too much but
it's just kind of it's just that
low-grade stress of gosh what if this
happens for like people right now get
yourself prepared and then you don't
need to think about it again until
hopefully you don't need it but maybe if
you do need it luckily you'll be
prepared you can't know what tomorrow
may bring
but you can have peace of mind knowing
that you will be ready with all that you
need all the ingredients our chef
prepared internally by wise company
they're terrific this is top of the line
it's an investment in peace of mind for
you and your family this week my
listeners get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product and an extra 25%
off the lowest marked price the time to
get it is now go there right now wise
food storage calm and then enter Knowles
Canada wles at checkout that's the only
way you're going to get 25% off the
lowest marks price do it today and then
don't think about it wise food storage
comm enter Knowles Cana wles a check out
or mention Knowles when you call eight
five five four five three two nine four
five plus shipping is free Wise has a 90
day no questions asked return policy
there is no risk in taking initiative to
get yourself in your family prepared
today wise food storage comm promo code
Knowles get any wise emergency or after
a food product at an extra 25% off and
free shipping we have got to get to what
this emotivism and this tyranny of
feelings means not just for politics but
culture and religion we'll get to that
with an evangelical losing his faith we
also have to get to if there is time the
more
details that are coming out in the
Jeffrey Epstein saga but first you got
to go to daily wire.com what do you get
what don't you get at this point you
give me you get the Andrew Klavan show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt Walsh oh you have to ask questions
in the mailbag coming up tomorrow so get
your questions in you get to ask
questions backstage that is coming up
we're going to be doing backstage live
next week so if you want to grab your
last-minute tickets make sure to go do
that ASAP I think we might still have
some left but not many so go over
quickly but most importantly you get the
leftist here's tumblr you need the
leftist here's tumblr if you even turn
on CNN these days you need it or water
will gush out of your TV glass will
shatter everywhere you will end up
floating with your face down in your own
bedroom because of all the leftist tears
not just from Fredo but from Don Lemon
to go over to daily wire.com get your
tumblr today we'll be right back
oK we've got to get to emotivism in
religion this is kind of a hobby horse
of mine that I've been talking about for
a little while this guy Marty Sampson is
his name he's a songwriter for the
popular evangelical Christian group
Hillsong UNITED he has just announced on
Instagram that he is quote genuinely
losing his faith this comes just a week
after an evangelical author named Joshua
Harris also announced that he no longer
calls himself a Christian this is a
problem I've been talking about for a
very long time when you ground your
faith in sentiment you leave your faith
in a very vulnerable position when the
bedrock of your beliefs
religious cultural or political is
emotivism it's just a faith in feeling
you are leaving your beliefs in a very
vulnerable position this is true
everywhere this is true throughout life
it's true on marriage a lot of young
people talk about this actually I mean
the baby boomers in particular because
they have those exploding divorce rates
when you ground your marriage in the
feeling of little butterflies that you
got when you were 16 and you saw your
girlfriend if that's actually the
bedrock of your marriage you're going to
get divorced guaranteed because the
minute those butterflies go away and
they will go away they might come back I
mean butterflies like they can come back
you can genuinely have feelings of
romantic love again and again I've seen
my grandparents do it they've been
married for 70 years but they're gonna
be periods where the butterflies go away
and if that's what your marriage is
based on it's gone you might as well not
get married this is not just an
evangelical problem we're seeing this is
going on in all sorts of ecclesial
communities this is going on in the
Catholic Church I mean there's I've
talked a lot about how the acoustic
guitar felt banner soapy sappy
sentimental saccharine liturgies that
have replaced really beautiful liturgy
in the Catholic Church have led a lot of
people away myself included it
contributed to my own lapsing in the
faith for for 10 years for a whole deck
it's a huge problem here's what Marty
Sampson had to say so this is on an
Instagram post he's since deleted it but
he still say 'zed grappling with his
faith and he said he's he's losing it
quote this is a soapbox moment so here I
go how many preachers fall many no one
talks about it how many miracles happen
now many no one talks about it
why is the Bible full of contradictions
no one talks about it
how can God be loved yet send four
billion people to a place all because
they don't believe no one talks about it
Christians can be the most judgmental
people on the planet they can also be
some of the most beautiful and loving
people but it's not for me I am NOT in
anymore
I want genuine truth not just the I
believe it kind of truth science keeps
piercing the truth of every religion
yeah okay lots of things help people
change their lives not just one version
of God got so much more to say but for
me I'm keeping it real
unfollow if you want I've never been
about living my life for others just
that last bit might show you the problem
might be your first problem if you can
claim to be a prominent Christian leader
and say with a straight face I have
never been about living my life for
others you probably weren't much of a
Christian leader probably didn't have
all that much faith to begin with I mean
everything he said is really stupid and
really wrong and really misguided but I
don't totally blame him for it what I
suspect which is true of a lot of people
today is that he did not have very much
of a formation in the faith what I
suspect is that this guy had a lot of
butterflies in his stomach and a lot of
soft soap and shallow feelings and then
when when that all went away when he
poked a little bit harder his faith was
based on nothing he just had an acoustic
guitar faith he had faith in acoustic
guitars not in the Czech Church not in
the faith but in those nice acoustic
guitar sappy songs that I don't even
think we're cool in the 70s but some
people apparently like them if your
faith can be broken by the nature of
miracle your faith can be broken by the
mysteries presented in Scripture or the
problem of evil
or the relationship between reason and
revelation or the
foundation of science itself he probably
didn't have a very sturdy faith to begin
with you just had sad sappy hallmark
music acoustic guitars this is an
example of the parable of the sower I
hope this guy is what's his name Marty
sent that Marty Sampson I hope he's
watching this I hope someone sends this
to him
this is the parable of the sower from
mark chapter four or from Matthew
chapter four I believe mark or Matthew
I'm not sure maybe my faith needs a
little needs to be average you've
intended as well but here is the parable
of the sower he was teaching them many
things in parables and in his teaching
he said to them listen behold a sower
went out to sow and as he sowed some
seed fell along the path and the birds
came and devoured it other seed fell on
rocky ground where it did not have much
soil and immediately it sprang up since
it had no depth of soil and when the Sun
rose it was scorched and since it had no
root it withered away other seed fell
among thorns and the thorns grew up and
choked it and it yielded no grain and
other seeds fell into good soil and
produced grain growing up and increasing
in yielding thirty fold and sixty fold
and a hundredfold and he said he who has
ears to hear let him hear
seems to me a pretty clear example of
seed falling on rocky ground where it
did not have much soil and it
immediately sprang up and had no depth
of soil and then the Sun rose and it was
scorched because it had no root and it
withered away this is Asim across the
board point that I make for all sorts of
people who call themselves Christian
follow the beauty and the goodness and
the truth don't let your emotions or
your self obsession or the acoustic
guitars that you really like as they
make you feel really good and cool carry
you away don't be carried away on thin
emotion you need to have a
serious foundation of your faith you
need to ballast yourself in reality then
throw yourself into the sea because the
sea is the inspiration but you need to
balance yourself in the reality first if
you just let yourself be washed away
wiped away blown away on the breezes of
your own thin emotion you are not going
to have very much faith at all this
especially matters with the evangelicals
because without the evangelicals the
culture and politics of this country are
lost they're the only reliably
conservative people in the country
Catholics aren't reliably conservative
Catholics aren't even reliably pro-life
now a lot of this gets down to a kind of
cultural Catholicism some people who say
yeah you know I went to church a few
times as a kid so I guess I'm Catholic I
don't practice the faith and I don't go
to church and I don't really believe any
of it but you know hey I'm Catholic
there was a study that just came out
from pew it said that something like two
thirds of Catholics don't believe in the
transubstantiation which is the
Eucharist really being the body and
blood of Christ that is this center of
the Catholic faith it's the center of
the mass yes and now I don't know if the
poll is right or not but I wouldn't be
terribly surprised and that's how you
get such bizarre numbers half of
Catholics saying they're not pro-life or
something like that evangelicals are
kind of the the political last hope in
the country and if if they're being
washed away because of shallow sappy
songs and not having a real firm solid
faith that is a very terrifying thing
you know it's it's funny sometimes I see
this a lot I go to a lot of conservative
religious circles and you'll see these
people who are super conservative across
the religious spectrum Catholic
Protestant evangelical and they ballast
themselves with such reality in every
aspect of their lives and then they give
in to sappy emotivism on a couple
questions
you know maybe they give in too sappy
emotivism on the gun control question
because they really let their emotions
run away with them or or even more
terrifying they give themselves into
sappy emotivism on the eternal questions
on the most important questions the
nature of reality the nature of the
human person and the nature of our
relationship to God himself not good not
good
very
scary and maybe this is an opportunity
for this guy Marty Sampson is that his
name I keep forgetting his name maybe
that's it this is an opportunity for
Marty Sampson and for other people who
currently have their faith mostly made
up of lame early 90s
soft rock melodies and lyrics to really
delve into those questions because
everything he brings up is are the
questions that children should bring up
and then a good religious formation will
answer them how many miracles happen
miracles happen every day buster they
happen all the time and the central
miracles of the scripture are incredibly
well attested to but miracles happen
every day but why is the Bible full of
contradictions what he's really saying
is I don't understand scripture
therefore it must be wrong no why are
you on why are you unwilling to engage
with Scripture what contradictions bring
up the contradiction explore them take
it seriously how can God be loved yet
send four billion people to a place all
because they don't believe what he's I
asking here is the problem of evil the
problem of pain the problem of suffering
you're not the first guy to think about
it you're not the first guy to ask that
question and acoustic guitar players are
yeah look I like acoustic guitar players
I'm an acoustic guitar player myself but
they're not the be-all and end-all of
philosophical and theological thought
and the question of theodicy maybe
explore what other people have had to
say on the matter the Church Fathers the
doctors of the church I want genuine
truth not the I just believe kind of
truth yeah you're right
you should have a genuine faith you
should follow that through reason you
know you know who didn't have it just I
just believe kind of truth you know who
followed genuine truth and used his
reason pretty seriously at st. Thomas
Aquinas one of the greatest geniuses to
ever live maybe he open his book up a
little bit maybe open up the Catechism
of st. Thomas Aquinas or the Summa
contra Gentiles or the Summa theologia
science keeps piercing the truth of
every religion no it doesn't that's just
a stupid slogan that left-wingers say
there that is
not true science is comes naturally from
the church the basis of science is
religious faith you need to accept the
premises of faith in order to think in
the first place and in order to follow
the scientific method and to trust your
faculties of reason there is a reason
why the greatest scientists in history
were all profoundly religious it's why
Isaac Newton spent the last 30 years of
his life interpreting Scripture it's why
Blaise Pascal one of the great
mathematicians and scientists of all of
modernity what came up with Pascal's
wager he was profoundly religious all of
these guys gotta use your mind the guy
who discovered the Big Bang do you know
who discovered the Big Bang a catholic
priest named father george lumetri the
guy who discovered the human genome all
of all of these people were profoundly
religious maybe they knew something that
you the acoustic guitar player don't
know I'm just keeping it real you're not
keeping it real you're allowing your
emotions to fall away with you you're
grounding your faith on nothing but your
own saccharine self-centeredness and you
should shake yourself out of it I've
never been about living my life for
others well then I guess you've never
been about Christianity buddy and if
you're interested in Christianity maybe
you should explore it with the Wonder
and awe of a child and not the cynicism
of a professional musician and the
saccharine sentiment of an acoustic
guitar player that's that's my rant on
that we have to ask a couple questions
about Jeffrey Epstein because a day
would no longer be a day if we weren't
able to find more lurid details at about
Jeffrey Epstein big question here is
over deep fakes uh I'm sorry we'll get
too deep fakes in tomorrow
the big question over Epstein I guess it
could be over deep fakes because we
don't know who they wheeled out of that
hospital but the big question here is
why didn't the guards check on him while
he was killing himself guards were
supposed to check on Epstein every 30
minutes at least if not every 15 minutes
what happened the story now coming out
of sources and investigators is that
they fell asleep for three hours while
Epstein killed himself both of them
the guards who were supposed to be
monitoring him apparently fell asleep
for three hours then they falsified the
records in the morning now they've been
placed on administrative leave and some
reports are coming out that the cameras
were just malfunctioning and so we
couldn't really see anything in or
around Jeffrey Epstein cell at all
I'm not surprised if the if bureaucracy
is incompetent not surprised at all I'm
also not surprised if bureaucracy is
corrupt and I think there are some
people trying to leap to this
incompetence theory but it just requires
so many coincidences it requires that
Epstein actually have been taken off of
suicide watch three weeks after an
attack it requires that the cameras have
not been pointed in the right place are
not working
it requires that records have been
falsified and it requires that not one
but two guards slept through three full
hours at the same time when they should
have been checking on Jeffrey Epstein
and it requires that all of this
happened right at the end of a news
cycle on the best time to release news
that you want to be buried to not have a
huge effect I'm skeptical not saying it
couldn't happen just saying I am
skeptical and if that level of
incompetence and coincidence occurred
that is a scandal in and of itself the
two guards have apparently been placed
on administrative leave okay I ain't
buying this I ain't buying this at all I
also can't wait to find out that the
guard the two guards is you know one is
a sort of taller man in his 70s with
gray hair the other one is a shorter
woman with blond hair and wears a lot of
pant suits you know kind of know I don't
know look I don't know what the guards
looked like they both had Groucho Marx
glasses on in the moustache I don't know
what they look like I'm saying it's the
Clintons people that's what I said now I
don't know I'm just saying there are
some people on the right and the left
who want to say okay open-and-shut case
nothing to see here move along move
along I don't buy that way too many
coincidences going on speaking of deep
fakes though the deep things either of
the supervillain now on his space
station because they will the deep fake
out of a and of a hospital there is a
big story on this we've got deep fakes
coming out it could really affect our
politics it could affect our culture a
lot of people are freaking out because
you can make people say or do anything
you want on video I actually think it's
a pretty good thing but I guess we'll
have to get to it tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show see them the Michael
Noel's show is produced by Rebecca
dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis Glover technical producer Austin
Stephens editor Danny D'Amico our audio
mixer is Mike Cora Meena hair and makeup
by Jeshua
L vera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Dole show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show in Hong Kong
pro-democracy demonstrators are waving
our flag the American flag the one-armed
millionaire athletes disrespect and CNN
complains about sort of tell us
something but what we'll talk about it
on the Andrew Klavan show
I'm Andrew Clavin